les filles nous accepte comment nous
accepte pas toujours alors on est bien
obligé de se satisfaire soi-même quoi
l'exposition de l'horrible à Paris en ce
moment propose à quelques privilégiés
des revues frappés de mesure
d'interdiction où s'arrête la protection
de la jeunesse ou commence la censure
une polémique qui n'a toujours pas fini
de faire du bruit reste que le sujet
n'est pas nouveau il existe depuis 1949
une commission de surveillance et de
contrôle des publications destinées à la
jeunesse elle étudie toutes sortes de
revues et donne un avis consultatif au
ministre de l'Intérieur à cette
commission un seul représentant de la
région une directrice d'école de Reims
comme ces 40 collègues de la commission
elle épluche les publications et traque
l'obsénité au fil des pages les filles
nous accepte comment nous acceptent pas
toujours alors on est bien obligé de se
satisfaire soi-même quoi et ça sert à
quelque chose bah oui à satisfaire qui
supprime aussi à la télé toutes les
chaînes pornographiques vous êtes contre
les scènes porno c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont illustrés quel âge il faut avoir
pour les lire
jusqu'à la nuit des temps il y aura des
gens pour et des gens contre la peine de
mort Dieu ou donc les revues porno
l'interdiction récente de quelques
publications grand public à cause de
leur caractère licencieux au
pornographique à relancer le débat au
plus tôt la polémique reste à savoir à
quel mot la loi a décidé de s'attaquer
les résultats eux ne sont pas toujours
ceux auxquels on s'attend comme par
exemple les kiosques qui avouent du fait
de l'interdiction une relance des revues
classées X de presque 30%. c'est le
réflexe du fruit défendu en fait au-delà
de cet aspect purement commercial dont
malgré tous les publications censurées
font les frais il y a les racines que le
législateur a décidé de combattre la
perversité qui menace les enfants
je pense que à partir du moment où une
revue
donne dans la perversité profonde elle
n'a pas besoin d'être lu par des enfants
ou par des jeunes de moins de 18 ans ils
ont à découvrir la vie il ne faut pas
leur faire découvrir dans un cocon bien
entendu il faut qu'il sache ce qui se
fait ce qui existe mais on n'a pas
besoin d'aller aussi loin que vont
certaines revues la commission de
surveillance et de contrôle des
publications destinées à l'enfance et à
l'adolescence ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
issue d'une loi de 1949 composé de
représentants de divers ministères ou
autres associations culturelles et
sociaux éducatives elle décortique
chaque revue pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui en dernier lieu interdit
la vente aux mineurs et au seul mineur
ou encore l'affichage voilà pour la
réglementation mais dans toute loi il y
a l'esprit et la lettre l'esprit lui
donne lieu très souvent à d'infini
interprétations qui conduirait le
législateur à de nombreuses Inter vous
pouvez deviner lesquelles en fait il
semble que le porno soit plus un
phénomène médiatique qu'une réalité de
la rue le juste milieu c'est peut-être
chacun dans sa tête qu'on le trouve
si vous surprenez votre fils avec une
revue porno vous l'engueulerez pas
et toi ça t'intéresse des revues
pornographiques
il y a des plus intéressantes que ça il
y a surtout que maintenant on fait des
BD il y a les 10 non je pense pas que ça
soit peut-être plus tard je sais pas
mais pas pour l'instant
dans ce magasin 3000 cassettes vidéos
15% sont consacrés à la pornographie 30%
la violence et au film fantastique
ensuite il concerne les cassettes
classées X seuls les personnes ayant
plus de 18 ans sont autorisés à les
louer pour le reste pas de
réglementation généralement c'est le
vendeur qui détermine si oui ou non le
client peut accéder au visionnage
les familles se disent à force de
multiplier les spectacles les cassettes
porno etc on incite des jeunes à devenir
eux-mêmes des criminels et finalement
c'est nos propres enfants qui en sont un
jour les victimes où ils viennent
eux-mêmes tortionnaires où ils viennent
victimes mais dans les deux cas c'est un
c'est un raté magistral de la société
c'est donc pour ces motifs que la
fédération des familles du Rhône a
entamé auprès des pouvoirs publics une
campagne de protection des mineurs
pourtant cette protection existe c'est
l'article 238 du code pénal il punit
fortement toute personne qui vend lou ou
donne gratuitement des films et
prospectus pas des personnes n'étant pas
majeur mais cette loi est-elle vraiment
appliquée oui nous répondons du côté de
la police et du tribunal de grande
instance un exemple sur cinq plaintes
posées courants mars 4 ou aboutis à des
condamnations parfois c'est même les
parents qui nous demandent des films
très violents pour leur enfant parce que
ça aime la violence
vous pensez que c'est une c'est une mode
oui c'est une mode pour la violence la
pornographie non j'ai pas demandé mais
la violence qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des familles qui portent plainte
justement contre les rondeurs de
cassette vidéo
là c'est question difficile vous me
piéger
qu'importe pleine contre la pornographie
je suis d'accord sur la violence bon
actuellement ça court les rues et je
pense que le gamin préfère voir et non
insister à quelque chose donc en voyant
une idée d'ailleurs le méchant est
toujours puni enfin
malheureusement le profit est parfois
prioritaire sur l'étude des bonheurs si
certains magasins respectent à la lettre
la loi d'autres la méconnaissent écouter
le témoignage de ces jeunes gens il est
très significatif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous les jeunes vous pouvez
prendre des cassettes pour nous prendre
des caissettes de violence
contre pas la carte d'identité
il est à noter que dans cette affaire le
ministre de la Culture a déclaré qu'une
fiscalité renforcée serait mise en place
et qu'un décret devrait mettre un frein
à la production de cassettes pour nous
violente
[Musique]